you know you can tell when you're the
world's greatest spy long sterling
bland sterling everyone knows the name
[Music]
don't take the law so hard I mean you
got to meet lance sterling
[Music]
thank you thank you two is too much it's
probably the right amount this thing at
home it is gonna change spying forever
it's called biodynamic concealment
imagine if I can make you wait for it
drawer oh please
disappear disappear disappear why are
you saying it like that for effect
that next generation concealment tech
you wouldn't happen to have it on hand
would you
I do happen to have it in hand show it
to me sure um what can I offer you a
drink I got water drinkable meals ready
mm-hmm
we had a drink Wow diet stuff has a
weird aftertaste
what's detect
it worked
[Music]
subject appears disoriented what did you
do hey Lance look at me look at you I
can't not look at you Walter I can see
my butt and your face at the same time
everywhere nobody notices them girl it's
the most perfect form of spy could take
I'm gonna unburn me right now that's it
I'm gonna play with you I'm Bert I'm
raising my voice I probably shouldn't be
raising my voice at you I need you to
unburnt me Walter you booted yourself
[Music]
you